the jurogan experience i am [ __ ]
nervous why for real yeah why
uh it's a no it's a good thing i haven't
left my [ __ ] house in a year
you've been totally locked up well i
mean i go to the grocery store
uh how'd you how did you avoid getting
it you didn't get it at all right
the cooties no no because everyone i
know was a shut-in too
and i [ __ ] loved it is it it's like
i left a day after my year anniversary
like i packed a week before coming here
so all you've done is go to the food
store
yep wow uh well i went up
uh to phoenix for new year's to see
uh it's a long story to see a dog that i
almost kept
uh but i gave away anyway so yes
basically
no i have not left [ __ ] bisbee
arizona in a year
wow and i didn't think it affected me
until i left it's like if you stayed in
bed
for a year going i don't need to walk i
know how to walk
and then after a year you're like [ __ ]
my legs
[Laughter]
what feels the weirdest just figuring
out how to pack for the road
i packed everything i drove and i left
sunday to be here wednesday it's a
13-hour drive
i could have done it in one shot
but i was so excited i'm gonna leave on
sunday
and just take the back roads and uh like
i
practiced talking on the phone before i
came here
an hour and a half before i'm just
calling people like i don't talk to
anyone
on the phone the only time i you know
use the phone
is to figure out where to meet you to
talk i don't
socialize on the phone you and i talk
maybe twice a year
tops and when i see it's you i go
do i have an hour okay i'll make an hour
because we don't but otherwise so i was
like
i haven't talked to people other than do
you have a room available
for three days three and a half days so
i was calling
you know bingo and brian hennigan going
just talk to me like
you don't i i packed what i thought was
a car load of [ __ ]
i forgot vodka which is my go-to drink
and a shirt i only had the t-shirt that
i was wearing that after three days
started to stink and i went
[ __ ] i didn't pack another shirt did you
go shirt shopping then yeah i went to
the thrift store oh
thrift store yeah of course yes
you notice that [ __ ] i did like i
brought two different
suits like goofy suits right i'm like
i've been wearing pajamas for a year
i would i think i would be even more
awkward if i was wearing a suit
especially with
stupid hair when did the goofy suits
become a thing with you like what year
1989 it started in telemarketing because
my mother would send me
goofy suits like that because they had
just gone out of style
like in that earlier that decade so
they're you know [ __ ]
it's like buying acid washed jeans now
yeah they're a [ __ ] nickel a pair at
the thrift store
jamie has a few pears acid wash sweat
pants oh yes
that's right sweatpants yeah
but that's your signature [ __ ] now the
goofy suit
yeah and i go i don't think i'm ready to
put on a goofy suit i don't know if it
it would clash with the goofy hair
because people will show up at my shows
in goofy suits
but they'll have like plaid on plaid and
you go no that doesn't work
like i i accessorize perfectly in a
goofy suit but i go i have the goofy
hair now is that like polka dots on
plaid i don't know
right have you gone too far yeah i want
to be comfortable here so i'm wearing
pajamas like i have for the last year
why don't you just wear pajamas that's
what i'm wearing
uh pajama pants are those pajama pants
yeah okay
there you go and this is uh this was my
old travel shirt i wore this
anytime i traveled like yeah i want to
be comfortable i don't want to
[ __ ] you've stayed within your mind
slipped very well
look you've never had to worry about
finances
like you've you you dialed that in early
yeah uh you never fell into the trap a
lot of people do
whether they like buy a bigger house or
buy a bigger
car or this or that my shit's paid for
after a year of not working i go
oh i always bragged about how much
[ __ ] i don't need to work
and then i go all right now i'm starting
to worry should i buy this dumb plastic
[ __ ] from
amazon or not
when do you think you're going to start
working are you going to get the vaccine
i got i got my first shot
which one the pfizer or the modern i got
my first shot
about two weeks ago two weeks ago
tomorrow
why is it funny because i just realized
i still have the [ __ ] band-aid when i
took a bathtub
i'm such a [ __ ] slothful pig when it
comes to bathing hilarious
and it's still there i didn't wash that
hard that it came off even last night
they're resilient those band-aids mm-hmm
they'll they'll stick around for a while
well i'm going to get my follow-up shot
two weeks from now just from the same
i know that's rude but i think it's
funny
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience